at this point you should have a
well-built cat clicker nice work now I'm
changing the requirements one more time
I promise this is the last time I change
requirements on you but I wanted to give
you an opportunity to fly on your own
we're going to add an admin mode when
you click the admin button it makes a
new area visible with the cat's name URL
and number of clicks if I go in and
change the name say too fluffy and then
I hit save it should update the model
with a new information and of course
tell the views to refresh which also
hides admin mode so what will you need
to add first of all you'll need to add
some HTML for the admin button and all
of this stuff here that'll probably
involve a button here a button here some
inputs labels and a form to contain
these and come to think of it you can
add a cancel button to in terms of the
model you'll probably want a property in
your model for whether or not the admin
view is showing you can set it to true
or false with your octopus function and
then based on whether it's true or false
the view will render this or not render
it in your view you'll have an init
function which you'll call once that'll
add the event listeners to all of these
buttons here just for a review adding
event listeners means we're telling
these elements to listen for certain
events in this case click events so one
of the user clicks we run the function
now what about the octopus in your
octopus you'll have a function for
opening the view when you press the
admin button a function for closing the
view when you press cancel and a
function for updating the current cat
with the new values when you press save
we'll call this version cat clicker
premium pro also remember that this
exercise here is not meant to be super
easy another thing to notice is that the
layout of my application keeps changing
that's to emphasize the fact that we're
not focusing on CSS your application
doesn't have to look necessarily very
pretty just as long as the functionality
is there once you're done it won't be a
ton of code but if it takes you a while
to do this that's by design do remember
that the more
when you work with well organized code
the easier changes like these will be